[Music]
what exactly is project butterfly is
vigilante as crazy as he acts and how
did peacemaker survive the event of the
suicide squad here's a quick explainer
about where the first few episodes of
peacemaker leave our patriotic hero
hey the reason i'm excited it is normal
if you didn't catch his appearance in
the suicide squad when it premiered last
summer peacemaker helpfully brings you
up to speed by showcasing exactly what
the title character is all about i
cherish peace with all my heart
i don't care how many men women and
children i need to kill to get it
what else do you need to know after the
battle against starro the conqueror in
corto maltese peacemaker is more or less
writer's reign despite getting shot in
the throat and getting a building
dropped on him you're shot in a building
falls on you
and all you have to replace is a
clavicle
you're the luckiest man alive
after getting recaptured shortly after
leaving the hospital peacemakers once
again back working for the government
though amanda wallace not his commanding
officer this time peacemaker's new boss
as clemson man a mercenary with a dark
reputation but it's not all new in
peacemaker the first hour of the series
brings a number of familiar faces back
from task force x including emilia
harcourt johnny conomos and briefly a
cameo from amanda waller herself we also
meet a new member of the team lyota
adebayo peacemakers racist father augie
smith and peacemaker's best human friend
slash biggest fan vigilante let's take a
look where they all end up in the first
three episodes of peacemaker
after following harcourt to a bar
peacemaker makes a series of passes at
his co-worker none of which work out
though peacemaker is immediately
attracted to harcourt he becomes even
more smitten when she violently takes
down a man who attacks her harcourt
later gives peacemaker a piece of her
mind not that he totally gets what she
has to say i have no interest in you
other than your ability to fight for us
just because you're handsome doesn't
mean you're not a piece of murderer i
think i'm handsome
when peacemaker begs for a no strings
attach deal between the two of them
harcourt appears to grow even less
interested and leaves well peacemaker
spends a significant amount of time in
the first episode focusing on sex
harcourt appears laser focus on the
finer details of her new job she sees
her placement on this specific task
force as punishment for her
participation in the mutiny against
amanda waller and the suicide squad and
wants to prove herself all over again as
walla herself later says barbie's
ambitious watch out for her
somewhat surprisingly viola davis has a
short cameo in the first episode as
amanda waller she appears in a short
video call with lyotar who in addition
to working as walla's eyes and ears on
this mission also happens to be her
daughter in keeping with her usual mo
waller is once again playing a game
outside the bounds of the stated mission
during her facetime call with leota
walla commands her to hide a forged
diary in peacemaker's trailer for
reasons that are initially known only to
her the exact purpose of the diary may
not be made immediately clear but given
the crying child on the cover it's
likely to paint a less than flattering
picture of peacemakers in a psyche but
to what end while amanda waller's exact
plan in the peacemakers series remains
unclear in the first three episodes it
seems certain that waller will seek the
double cross peacemaker and the rest of
the team eventually
leos is not the only character and
peacemaker with an interesting parent
who is difficult to deal with terminator
2 star robert patrick plays peacemakers
appallingly racist father augie when
peacemaker first arrives at his dad's
home his dad is visibly displeased to
see him while agi is briefly amused at
the story of bloodsport's childhood
trauma his main response to his son's
war stories is rooted in disappointment
at his son's insistence agi gives him
another peacemaker branded helmet as it
turns out peacemaker's new helmet ends
up coming his way at just the right time
after getting rejected by harcourt the
peacemaker goes home with annie a random
woman at the bar unfortunately as a
casual encounter is on the cusp of
wrapping up that same woman seems to go
completely feral stabbing peacemaker and
throwing him through a wall it isn't
until peacemaker is reunited with his
helmet that he is able to gain the upper
hand by activating a new feature the
sonic boom considering how effective
agi's helmet tech seems to be in this
first episode we can't help but wonder
if these other helmets will be utilized
at some other point this season the
other power up options in the lab offer
features as varied as a full body force
field an underwater breathing apparatus
and x-ray vision tech in a post-credit
sequence agi even shows peacemaker a
helmet that literally just infects its
wearer with scabies just because
i just want to give you scabies
give me skip why do i want scabies
challenge yourself
every man should have scabies once in
his life
the motivations for annie sturphausen's
attack on peacemaker in the first
episode aren't entirely clear to the
team at first murn notes that the entire
operation has been kept off the books
and he can't understand how anyone could
have known that peacemaker was a part of
it harcourt suggests that amanda waller
might have been behind it after leota
insists that it's not waller harcourt
even begins to question the yota's
placement on the mission eventually
however peacemaker remembers that he
caught annie reviewing the classified
materials provided to him by mern
including a dossier detailing the
mission to assassinate a sitting u.s
senator while harcourt has proven wrong
in her initial accusations against leota
this specific encounter has clearly
raised her suspicions of her newest
colleague we can't imagine that harcourt
or any of the other team members will
react positively when they find out that
waller and leota are keeping an
important part of the mission plan a
secret
we can't call it entirely shocking to
discover that peacemaker's father is a
character like a white dragon augie
smith isn't exactly excited to see his
son return home and he's quickly
revealed to be a vile homophobe and
racist now that aagi finds himself in
prison after johnny kimonos frames him
for peacemaker's crimes he is shown to
command a vast number of fiercely loyal
white supremacist followers in some ways
this is a fitting adaptation from the
peacemaker comic book series in which
peacemaker's father wolfgang schmidt is
a former commandant of a nazi
concentration camp during world war ii
since the last concentration camp was
liberated by the allies in may of 1945
and peacemaker is set in the present day
the math wouldn't quite allow for the
same origin story without some changes
in the comics william heller aka white
dragon is unrelated to peacemaker but
considering the comic character's white
supremacist motivations and appearances
in the suicide squad comic books this
new configuration turns out to be a
natural fit
peacemaker is definitely one of those
characters who just seems to stumble
into earth-shattering revelations after
a long set of failures vigilante
convinces peacemaker to let loose by
celebrating his release from prison with
a mixture of controlled substances
firearms and explosives however the
day's festivities don't stop peacemaker
from mistakingly learning more about his
upcoming mission while smoking marijuana
with vigilante and amber peacemaker
starts fiddling around with the alien
looking device he stole from annie's
house when peacemaker touches a button
on the device it quickly expands and
forms what appears to be a tiny
spaceship by the time the second episode
wraps up it's unclear who or what
purpose such a small vessel could serve
but it has to be tied to project
butterflies somehow
episode 3 puts the deadly capabilities
of vigilante on display for the first
time following peacemakers and ability
to pull the trigger at the home of
senator royland gough vigilante takes
control of the mission by executing
three of the four targets after
peacemaker and vigilante are captured by
goff vigilante is unmasked and tortured
unfortunately for vigilante peacemaker
refuses to give up any information even
going so far as to tell goff to
basically do his worst torture wise does
that change your mind sorry pal not for
sale
what give it all you got vigilante is
visibly shocked when peacemaker refuses
to spare him any torture and appears
genuinely hurt a peacemaker's lack of
empathy for him given peacemakers prior
actions what could possibly make
vigilante surprised by peacemakers and
flinching response maybe vigilante
really is as delusional as he seemed to
be still even if vigilante is
peacemaker's number one fan losing part
of a pinky toe is bound to drive a wedge
into even the hardiest to friendships it
doesn't seem like these two would-be
superheroes are quite that close to
begin with dude i'm your best friend
maybe not
to quote dead leads of spider-man
homecoming most people would probably
agree that john econ emmos seems like an
archetypal guy in the chair hey
can i be your guy in the chair
what
you have this guy
with a headset telling the other guy
where to go
however episode three forces hikano most
to quite literally jump out of his chair
and face a threat directly as harcourt
leota and mirn move in on the house
where peacemaker and vigilante are held
hostage by a butterfly economos realizes
that judo master is escaping the scene
in a vehicle jon ultimately rises to the
occasion crashing the team's van
directly into judo master's car and
later pummeling the martial artist with
a tire iron that might be a big win for
john's ego but the bigger question is
where judo master was driving to before
goff starts to torture vigilante for
answers he tells judo master
take the tunnel to the forest
from there get to glen ty let them know
what's occurred here yes
presumably there are other butterflies
maybe even more important ones on the
senator once they find out about
peacemaker's mission how are they going
to react
after peacemaker gangsia behind the game
senator goff he fires a single shotgun
blast into goff's face and that's that
right in most cases this would mean the
end of goff's character but not on
peacemaker as peacemaker and vigilante
prepare to reunite with the rest of the
team upstairs the two noticed a small
creature calling out to the face of the
late senator as a creature takes to the
sky with a flapping of its wings
peacemaker knowingly remarks
oh
project butterfly
that's when the episode ends with the
tease that suspected butterflies all
over the world episode 3's reveal that
the literal butterfly inside senator
goff's head is a major clue to the
entire mission at large a subject about
which peacemaker actually knows
frighteningly little it's a goal to kill
all butterflies or just the ones that
amanda waller once dead when peacemaker
gives mum intel that proves that the
seemingly happy family of four is
actually entirely composed of
butterflies the task force captain
quickly relays orders to kill them all
does this mean all butterflies are as
dangerous as a woman who attacks
peacemaker in episode one considering
the fact that we've only seen them
attack peacemaker either in self-defense
or after discovering his assassination
plan they might not even be malevolent
regardless given everything we've
learned about the group so far it seems
fairly obvious that literally anyone
even people we think we know could
secretly be a butterfly
many of the post-credit scenes in
peacemaker work as jokey extensions of
scenes from the episode rather than
material that's critical to the plot
episode 3's post-credit sequence takes
us back to the moment when vigilante
reveals himself behind the bushes
outside the home of senator garth as
harcourt prepares for the possibility
that vigilante could ruin the entire
mission she issues a menacing threat if
you [ __ ] up this mission i will kill
your family oh okay good luck a little
late for that
you guys got beer considering this
character's particular proclivity for
violence it doesn't seem like a big
stretch to guess that vigilante might
even be the one responsible for his
family's deaths in the vigilante comic
series adrian chase takes on the
vigilante persona after his wife and
children are murdered by the mob while
it's possible this series is simply
alluding to the original character's
comic history we think it's more likely
this character has an intensely more
absurd background in episode 2 vigilante
admits to peacemaker that in prior years
he would have killed him for smoking
marijuana and he seems similarly extreme
in his response to other crimes when i
find out someone murdered an innocent
person or sold somebody heroin or
did some graffiti and i killed that
person
perhaps vigilante's family members
simply chose a bad time to jaywalk
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]